[musique]
Jeter Ce n'est pas rapporté dans les médias, mais c'est beaucoup
Gouache et peignage
ça va être un gros problème
je n'ai pas l'âge
[musique]
Beaucoup de gens ne peuvent pas manger de riz.
J'avais l'habitude de penser que les amis vagabonds étaient mes amis
déjà bien
Il y a aussi des jeunes et c'est assez difficile
Ouais
Ouais ouais ouais
Après le livre d'images, ce riz alpha s'est répandu, et ma mère a dit que c'était un stock de riz qui pouvait être reconstitué avec de l'eau ou de l'eau chaude.
comme maté calorique
et ce doit être un fruit
2.5 La vente est un nombre extraordinaire
Je pense que cela a un grand impact sur l'esprit, donc la consultation d'aujourd'hui porte sur le travail lié à l'événementiel.
Mais ce coup dit que c'est parti
[musique]
Ouais
Si vous allez au bureau du gouvernement pour demander de la nourriture, vous devez être dans une fête.
On m'a dit d'aller au bureau d'assurance sociale de Shampukusho pour le moment et de les consulter.
Cependant
D'une certaine manière ça
[musique]
En outre, en tant que système dit social, les employés réguliers et le soutien familial sont limités dans une certaine mesure.
s'attendait à ce que
C'est un système, donc quand ça déborde de là, c'est un siècle sinueux
Quand ta relation avec ta famille n'est pas bonne
Je pense qu'il y a un moment où il est facile de devenir en bonne santé, alors c'est à quoi ça ressemble.
Je pense que quelqu'un comme Nikusa a pas mal de caractéristiques.
[musique]
cerceau